hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on Monster World again and
today we're gonna be talking about cool
Vitara that which is the new monster
added into monster hunter world I'm
pretty sure I butchered her name so I'm
gonna be calling her - Rob throughout
the remainder of the video but basically
we're gonna be showing you today how to
get this each quest and how to defeat
her by giving you simple tips and
pointers as well as checking out her
moveset in the surrounding areas and
then showing off the rewards we get at
the end as always like the video if you
enjoy subscribe if you're new I cover
lots of them lots of Monster Hunter
content I have a lot of solo guides on
the older monsters as well some how-to
guides and tips to help you guys become
better Monster Hunter players and with
that let's get started
so first up is the basically how to get
beasts each quest so once you spawn in
you have to do the same thing you did
with deviljho and find these tracks on
investigations and expeditions and your
scalp eyes will be blue once you're near
them since suratha is an elder dragon I
found mine on the ancient forest of my
first attempt but it's usually trial and
error so hopefully you get lucky once
you find one singular track or footprint
or marker anything whatever it happens
to be go back to astera and the Admiral
will be there waiting for you after
going through some dialogue your then
caster reporting to the celestial
pursuit aka the gathering hub to start
the siege once that is taken care of get
a team of four for your squad and fight
to wrath now this fight is scaled for
multiplayer so doing the solo will be
very difficult I usually like to play my
stuff in solo but obviously I had to go
to multiplayer for this instead
obviously like I said skills in
multiplayer type modes so just basically
hop in join a session and hopefully
someone has the quest by now by the time
the video should be uploaded over the
time you're watching this most people
should probably have it when I got it I
had to wait a few minutes because not
many people got it as quick as I did but
the tutorial for the fight explains the
pursuit level is info gathered on top
this based off of everyone's
contribution so higher the rank the
better the chance you have of completing
the objectives and for the reward level
you can increase that by completing
research entries your main objective for
this is to break off two roth's horns
now you can beat this by simply
repelling her away and she runs away but
to get the maximum Ward's you have to
break her horns off for the recommended
gear I recommend having
mega potions with the vitality and rock
steady mantle if you can't get the rock
steady man so let's completely find that
2hr fifty-plus just make sure you have
the vitality mantle
if you do have room bring the health and
affinity boosters for the team to heal
them up as well as some life powder or
hardshell powder any of that good stuff
to share with the team is that
everybody's on equal footing and as well
bring some cool drinks when you get into
the lava areas now for the actual quest
once you spawn and you go with your
squad
you should find any cannon or sling or
ammo that you can and shoot them at to
Roth stomach you know you're doing this
correctly once her skin has gray stretch
marks or any type of scratching meaning
that it's been affected and get
potentially break soon find the camp and
find the cannon positions by running up
ahead of her having them ready to fire
when she comes around or shoot your
sling or ammo at the top of her there
should be some boulders on the ceiling
to crush her each of these are beautiful
ways to basically numb down her health
then you can tell once you're done
because you've done enough damage when
she starts to scream then she's gonna
run away you track her down to the
second area where you actually fight her
you want to keep breaking her body by
destroying the areas near her tail and
stomach to continue progressing through
this mission moving on since this is
actually where she starts to fight you
now let's get to her move set her main
attacks she consistently uses is this
rollover move the move is pretty
self-explanatory she basically rolls
over and tries to flatten you simply by
running away or if you get caught then
Superman dive by sheathing your weapon
and jumping you shouldn't get all this
damage pretty easily just don't jump too
early or the end of the tail will flick
you at the end so just got trying to get
that perfect balance and medium point
her next move is the head boat where she
goes forward and pushes her head forward
same procedure applies in terms of
dodging simply running away from it
dodge rolling or Superman diving will
work just fine and then next up is this
breath attack and this move comes out
pretty quick so if you happen to have a
faster reaction you can dodge the move
by Superman jumping sadly I happen to go
I happen to get hit but my vitality
mental saved me in the fight and didn't
really cost me any of my health if
you're quick enough though you can
Superman dive out a bit like I said but
you mostly want to avoid her face since
that attack hurts the most and obviously
you're not gonna be doing much since
you're you should really be focusing on
her stomach and tail to get those parts
out of her so she so you can progress
the next move she has is this tail swipe
move which has incredible range I mean
look at this goddamn range
it's obviously because of her long ass
tail so Superman diving or being in
front of her or on the sides will negate
all the damage since our tails in the
back
just don't be confused with this move
because it's only when she looks back
and moves her tail most of her time her
tail moves around but that's because
she's turning to face any any type of
other opponent or walk away not trying
to sweep you so keep that in mind she
also has a claw swipe swimmer tuner
Dante's move but it's only the swipe
doing the normal dodge roll or Superman
dive can negate this damage just like
we've talked about before and then
lastly is the ground pound slam moving
out of range of this and not even
needing to dodge or anything like that
will negate the damage and since she has
a slower recovery time on this you can
punish her tail and stomach or horns if
you get to the end while she tries to
get up after enough punishment her
scales should turn mullen and the
handler should mention that during the
quest now her tail and back do tons of
damage so have your team focus on that
and chip away her body parts doing
enough damage will cause her to retreat
and move on to the third area now for
the third area this is where you want
the cool drinks since they do come in
handy since the entire area is basically
lava simply repeat everything from the
initial fight in the second area then
begin hitting her stomach and tail to
break her body parts off when her body
turns molten but if you're smart enough
or have a dumb enough to Roth you could
bake her into the lava fountains that
sprout up and caused tons of damage to
her in my game she ended up rolling into
a lava fountain Kaza and causing her to
lose all of her armor almost instantly
and becoming really skinny and we guys
done with this area within about a
minute and a half you can also shoot the
lava icicles on the ceiling for extra
damage but I found that the lava
fountain does the most and it's really
easy to bait her into it once she looks
skinny and her huge coat of gold armor
is off you're on to the last area of the
mission
now since Tara doesn't have a huge coat
of gold anymore she moves a lot quicker
and does moves a lot quicker so
definitely keep that in mind during this
stage of the fight for this stage though
you want to focus strictly on her horns
and face since to beat this you have to
break her horns like I said you can win
by repelling her but you get more
rewards if you break the horns which
we'll get into later use barrels
explosives anything you can to get these
horns off so you can reap these rewards
before she leaves she does one extra
move in this phase that does devastating
damage and that is this fire AoE move
she gets on her hind legs and does this
fire AoE attack like I said does
incredible amounts of damage to you if
you're behind her it goes all the way to
her ball or the beginning of her back
feet so roughly around there you should
be in the safe zone or if you're facing
her head-on just
keep moving back as this spreads way
quicker in the front than it does the
back eventually the screen will turn red
this means molten gold will be flooding
from the ceiling so not only do you have
to watch out for her moves you have to
watch out for the molten gold on the
ceiling raining down on you this does do
decent damage but it isn't enough to
one-shot you after some time though to
Roth will leave and you will win by
repelling but if you manage to break her
horns you can also complete the quest
and get extra rewards for it and this is
where the fun part comes in so now once
you're done go back to the gathering hub
and go back to the tab that says to Roth
siege and press claim rewards I got
melted parts and a bunch of other
goodies for this so all you have to do
is this a couple times you'll get tons
of different loot but that's not all you
can also get these types of hybrid
weapons I ended up getting three insect
leaves three hunting horns and some
other weapons as well my longsword that
I received was rarity 7 and it looks
like a cross between the truth which is
that gold type of tent and then the topi
kodachi which was the white feathers
type looking thing compared to the
normal stats on the Toba kodachi
longsword compared to her often tobe
hybrid mine was better by about a 20%
difference on affinity I may have gotten
a bad roll but either way it does better
than the base one and you can get tons
of different weapon variations because
I'm assuming they're including every
single type so you can then get a
longsword that's - Rafa and Jeanette and
then Ratheon and then there's all these
different types allowing for basically
an endless grind
even though sadly this is a limited time
event now remember these weapons are
only available if you happen to break
two roth's horns if you if you win by
repelling you don't get this for the
armor though in particular it's going to
be costing lots of shells and scales
since there are so much of a plentiful
of them when you fight her as well as a
nerd gurgaon teh vol huzzah can easy
nogf a gem and Interop golden glim stone
i believe you get you need two of those
so lots of grinding will need to happen
to get the full set especially on the
even the other monsters if you happen to
not have those elder dragon gems for the
skills with the helmet this comes with
free element ammo up and agitator the
torso is stone resistance and critical
boost
Gollancz our free element / ammo up and
power Pro longer pants our free element
ammo up and handicraft legs are wide
wide range and peak performance so there
is three out of the five of these have
free element and ammo up so definitely I
would say that that I believe the helmet
is better because of the
cater perk personally to me I like the
torso for the Sun resistance and
critical boost because you can never go
wrong with enough critical boost
especially with during this fight
obviously you can do mix sets and all
that other cool stuff to bank the best
Bill possible that's entirely up to you
the pellicle armor also has two versions
it's the samurai set which records bushi
tickets and the tera set which requires
tail shells scales and then regular
shells which you can like I said get by
breaking a farmer body once you collect
these rewards and then rinse and repeat
for more loot to end the video on some
general tips blow her up on the first
area focus on the stomach and tail in
the second and third area then for the
final one hit her horns until she breaks
them and then she leaves another tip is
to collect every piece of material
footprint anything you can it so that
you can raise your research level as
well as getting more materials for the
armor but what if you raise your
research level you can gain more time in
the ending phase causing her to stay in
that area longer so that you have more
time to beat her horns up and then
actually break them that was one of the
issues in the first time I fought her
she ended up leaving because we didn't
have enough time but majority the people
I ended up solo queueing with and all
those other cool guys that I played with
we ended up having a really high type of
research level so we had tons of time to
kill her but she almost got away but we
happen to break her horns just in time
if you have any tips that I didn't
mention that you would love to share
with any of your fellow hunters
definitely leave that in the comments
below quick shout out to the guys that I
played with solo King and egg roll
highly doubt that you're even watching
this video but on the small chance that
you happen to check this out thanks for
the games boys we definitely kick that
bosses ass I think we beat it in about
15 minutes which is absolutely
incredibly fast so GG for that boys but
like I said that's going to be the end
of the video today guys hope you guys
did enjoy this quick guide up for koval
to Roth I'm pretty sure once again I
butchered that name well [ __ ] it because
I'm probably gonna get bitched at in the
comments for this anyway
tell me in the comments below if you
happen to beat this and if you beat it
what were the type of weapons you got
like like I said I got a shitload of
insect lives and hunting horns I don't
really use those weapons too much so
that really didn't help me but I want to
know what you guys got really loved it
know like DVD feed enjoy it really does
help me out subscribe if you're new like
I said in the beginning I got tons of
Monster Hunter solo guides for the other
previous monsters like the Elder Dragons
and stuff like that I also have how-to
guides and other stuff for the event
quests on how to beat those and how to
get some other cool stuff like the Mega
Man outfit
Pooky be outfit and all that cool stuff
my two most recent videos are gonna be
on screen if you guys do want to check
that out with that guys hope you have a
great rest of your day enjoy that boss
and I'll see you guys later peace out